[Music]
today we remember those lives lost on
one october a sunrise ceremony
commemorated the shooting victims
victoria saha reports how the community
honored the victims
it's definitely a somber day four years
after the shooting las vegas continues
to grieve hundreds gathered here behind
me at the government center to honor and
remember those 58 lives lost and two
that died later
here we are
a community still remembering the
fateful night of 1 october 2017.
unfortunately
this tragedy
will live on
in our lives and in our memories forever
survivors and families of victims came
together to share their grief joni
hackney survived the shooting massacre
that took 60 lives and injured hundreds
more i still grieve every day but i
i think there's something about these
events that make me so grateful that i
was
a survivor her group of friends all
survived and come to the remembrance
ceremony every year to honor the ones
who didn't
every year it's a remembrance of
what's important and the people in your
life terry davis did lose friends at the
concert the wound will never close
entirely though the years following have
been difficult the route 91 concert
goers have formed a family you know
vegas has a history of forgetting things
well you know it used to our slogan used
to be what happens in vegas stays in
vegas
as a survivor
and
you know a part of this group we would
like to see people never forget
those survivors tell me that this day is
always very hard for them but seeing
familiar faces for the past four years
has helped them in their healing process
reporting from the clark county
government center victoria saha live
local now